I have good news for you today.
Is that a bad person lost their job.
But it's still all wrapped in terrible news,
which is that Fox News is still combining
with the Trump administration to continue
spreading violent disinformation about the
virus.
I'm talking now about former Fox News host
Trish Regan.
Really a vile person.
Trish Regan was until recently a Fox Business
Channel host.
She went on one of the most unhinged Trump
defending Corona virus, minimizing rants that
we've ever seen.
Just a couple of weeks ago.
And Fox has said bye bye to her, although
we don't yet know exactly why.
Check out the first part of this bizarre rant.
Everything about it is wacky and deranged.
This was, again, a couple of weeks ago when
we knew this was a crisis.
Take a look.
We've reached a tipping point.
The chorus of hate being leveled at the president
is nearing a crescendo as Democrats blame
him and only him for a virus that originated
halfway around the world.
This is yet another attempt to impeach the
president.
And sadly, it seems they care very little
for any of the destruction they are leaving
in their wake.
Losses in the stock market.
All this, unfortunately, just part of the
political casualties for them.
You know, this is a time to be united, not
to be pointing fingers, not to be encouraging
hate.
And yet, what do we see?
We see the absolute opposite from the left
tonight.
Good evening, everyone.
I am Tricia Regan.
The heat is boiling over.
Many in the liberal media using and I mean
using Corona virus in an attempt to demonize
and destroy the president.
This monologue, which should really be exhibit
A media literacy classes for distinguishing
between news and opinion, identifying bias,
identifying unstable people, maybe in a psychology
class.
It went on for five minutes and really it
peaked at the end when Trish Regan couldn't
even keep her nonsense straight off of the
teleprompter, sort of got lost in her own
teleprompter white while continuing to in
a completely unhinged fact free way, defend
Donald Trump and minimize the virus.
Here's the wrap up to her lunatic soliloquy
for the media to spin a narrative that this
sell off and this virus are all a result of
President Trump.
It's just wrong.
But unfortunately, I guess they needed someone
to blame.
They were looking for someone to blame.
They want to blame him for literally anything
they can.
And they have no real interest, shall we say,
in finding who's to blame.
Who is the root cause of all this?
From what we can tell, this all originated
out of China.
When Donald Trump is their political target,
that's all they need.
And that's tonight's Intel.
So the good news is bye bye.
Trish Regan, the bad news is Fox is still
a disaster.
It's also not clear that this rant is why
she was fired.
It may be it may not be.
Fox has only been saying, you know, we thank
Tricia and we wish her continued success.
So we don't even really know the full reality
of it.
One idea is that Trish Regan may sort of be
like the sacrificial lamb for all of Fox News,
because you've got the Fox and Friends clowns
in the morning talking about flying around
and going to restaurants and wanting to get
their nails done.
You have Sean HANNITY talking about how vaping
might protect you from Corona virus and suggesting
unproven prophylactic treatments for the virus.
According to reporter Gabriel Sherman, Fox
News is actually worried about possible legal
liability for their Corona virus downplaying.
So maybe they're tossing Trish Regan out of
there to say, hey, listen, we took it seriously.
We pulled her off the air, we cut ties with
her.
We did the right thing while allowing everybody
else to continue spouting the nonsense.
So that's Trish Regan.
We do have one more Fox News related story
today, which is about that lunatic right wing
Judge Jeanine Pirro, who appeared visibly
drunk during her weekend program, also presumably
being produced from her home.
At this point.
So let's talk about that one next.